[Music]
the sewage
so here's the deal I'll whip up a little
potion to make you human for three days
got that three days
before the sun sets on the third day you
and princy must share a kiss and not
just any kiss
the kiss of true love
if you do you will remain human
permanently
but if you don't
[Music]
know
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
World a man was drowning I had to save
him this obsession with humans has to
stop I just want to know more about them
[Music]
the Wilderness you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
watching you'll see me
someday I'll be
[Music]
he's a human you're a mermaid that
doesn't make us enemies
[Music]